oh hello everyone thanks from you here I
am over frenzy I'm a little engineer for
alpha health I'm from a solana and I
will tell you about how we are
validating evolving and illuminating
data in real time first of all I would
like to share my slides I know that data
Council will share later through Twitter
but if you want to review it now during
I'm talking or to send it to your
colleagues here you have the the link so
you could access right now
I will wait just a few seconds if you
want to take a picture or like entering
in your browser okay perfect and then
let's proceed I will like to introduce
myself before like going to the talk so
you have a more background about me and
all the data journey that I did that
end up like providing this validation
and evolution and Malaysian system no I
started like six years ago more or less
I drove it so it is a company based in
Barcelona also like it's a marketplace
aggregator of marketplaces there I
started working with a map reviews storm
and solar I don't know if any is anyone
here that work with MapReduce ok it's
quite from the past but I really believe
that if there is people now is starting
to work with a spark Map Reduce should
be a must because it helps you to know
all the neighbors that you have with
shuffling data and with partitioning so
then when you code spark it's you are
more prepared and more aware of this
challenge then I move to shifted now no
as a vinta there i was working with a
redshift everything with sequel then we
move to to spark python and as a scholar
spark will constrict everything with
region then we implement some jupiter
service and also we implemented data
quality tooling in real time using Kafka
and elasticsearch so everyone all
developers across all the marketplaces
that savy was here before explaining
we're aware of the the quality of the
data in real time so they could fix it
as quickly as possible
and then one year ago I moved to two
alpha for health health company based in
Barcelona where we were working with a
lot of Amazon technologies like lambdas
kinases and also we're using some open
source tools like read ash I flow and
then the elasticsearch stack but let's
focus on what matters
no what I'm here to talk about the
validation evolution and an organization
in this talk I will cover these topics I
will start talking about the challenge
that we have and are for health then I
will move to introduce you the be8 akka
baya for the friends then I will cover
the validation devolution and the new
mutation and finally I will wrap up with
some learnings that were witty about our
journey so the data challenge at alpha
health it's a it's a moon shooter where
your main goal is to solve mental mental
clinical disease by using data what
implies that is that we need to provide
a really health quality no and for that
we need a really good quality of the
data then since we're a moon shooter and
we are prototyping a lot we are
iterating faster we need to evolve now
we are need this to be capable of
evolving so sometimes something that
sure we a frog can be a penguin
so for these things you need to be ready
to evolve and also since we are in alpha
health we are working with electronic
health records and that implies that is
really a sensitive data and for these
reasons we need to like war
properly with anonymize it that's why we
develop be a bear for doing not only
these for covering this challenge now we
have the validation we have the evolving
and then we have the anonymization if we
try to map these parts to the challenge
that I've introduced before we have that
for good quality we are validating for
prototyping we are evolving and then for
the health records we are anonymizing
what we have we provided a lambda lambda
function in Amazon when we have an input
of data we have an input of stream right
now is kinases and then we split now we
provide three outputs two different
outputs that I will explain later one of
them is the ballot and the last test
that is evolved then another one is the
invalid and then we have done randomized
that we have three different outputs I
will like to highlight that we are
splitting the ballot and letters from
the ballot data we don't want to end up
with invalid data with the same of the
other ballot because when you are trying
to solve mental issues when you are
trying to to improve the health quality
of the people you don't want to train
models with bad quality because maybe
instead of improving the quality of the
health you are just destroying them well
kind of but the thing is that we were
fair lights are split then you fix the
invalid data and then you can move it
again to the ballot folder or the the
ballot stream but be aware that it's
better to don't process data then
process something that is wrong if we
take a look inside the lambda the the
flow that is following the data it's
like when it goes inside we validate
first of all then we know if it's
invalid or not I will cover that later
if it's invalid we just throw it away
and then we need to evolve this data now
the the data as I'm saying a we iterate
we have prototypes that cannon
as a product or the same prototypes come
by what or can make some iterations so
we need to evolve this data that can be
like it has multiple iterations so for
each iteration with validate again
because it can be that maybe some
evolution has wrong and then once we
have the latest version we anonymize it
and the identified part we have store it
so we end up with three different output
streams also I would like to share how
this data ends in the inner storage
layer just so you have more information
some more background about how this data
end in s3 we're in Amazon by the way so
we have a color as a privacy we are
using different colors one is the green
is that no sensitive data is aggregated
we can have weather data
I don't know aggregated data but it's
not a Doozer level so it's like a
summary stats then we have amber is
animated data so with the data that
don't contain sensitive information then
we have the red one and the raw data now
we like to we love to have raw data we
don't touch it but in case that we
messed up in our system we still have
some days to recover from this process
also by having different colors it
allows us to have different retentions
as you know now GDP our first you like
more or less they identify a data it
should be 12 months or less and also you
can define even shorter periods also by
having colors and products you can have
different policies to access this data
so you can have your data scientists
people having only REIT access to the
amber and not to the red or different
kind of things that it will depend of
your needs okay I introduced via then go
to the hobby validate for validating we
need schemas today there were some talks
that were introducing schemas no
so what is in a schema a schema is the
DNA of the data that it defines the
structure the content the quality and
the format by having a good data schema
by habit by understanding your data then
you can have better understanding of
your users and also to produce better
products
if you don't define properly your data
then you cannot understand what means
the data if you don't understand what
means the data your products
well maybe are not going to be good
enough not because you understand what
is happening at the end so there are
different standards of schemas there is
a schema.org that is JSON doc just means
Chema's dot orc in that case we are
using that one there are also another
ones but this JSON is Chema's it's quite
helpful it's quite friendly for user and
machines to define how the data she
looks so at our health we decided to use
that one also there is some repositories
or some open-source libraries that are
using this JSON is Chema's to validate
the data that one every every dot org
JSON a schema is really powerful it's an
open source we also contribute I will
show later a whole but I will recommend
that is in Java before going further to
show some code I would like to show some
schemas how they look this is a based
even where we define what is a user what
is a product what is like when it was
created which the schema is using the
source of the data and then the good
part about using insisting schemas is
that you can compose them so you can
have a product I'm using it here I can
have a user and I reference this one
component composing schemas then I also
can inherit them in that case I have a
device Evan that is inheriting all the
previous fields of the previous
definition plus adding some device
information this device field that it
has a
reference to the devised schema and
finally if I need to send some sensors
data because we won't like to infer what
is happening with the users then I can
like okay this is a device sensor Evan
is in a written from the device Evan
that has also device Evan and it's
adding one of these schemas no this one
is schemas you can compose by specifying
all off any off or one off so you have
multiple kinds of reference of composing
if we go to some more visual know some
more a detective wait to show this
schema we have the best one that it has
the product user deploy environment we
have the source they created the schema
then the vise divine it has the device
and then the device and for Evan it has
the same source data one thing that is
quite powerful about composing schemas
is that you can have multiple products
or multiple needs or requirements that
they use this ones so you can develop
them some systems or some other products
on top of these reusable compounds these
resource models that could be for
example you have multiple prototypes all
of them share the product thing or the
device and then it's like then it's less
effort for your developers and also
although your data scientists can just
use that across all the products that
they are working on let's go to the code
how it looks as I said we are using the
average dark decision schema library
it's an open source you can contribute
is really well documented right now they
support if you know the jitney schemas
there are different versions they super
until diverged from seven recently there
is the version eight but seven was the
latest one until September so what we
need we need a schema at the an
association and then we will load this a
schema we load it there we have
client as you know as you as you saw
there are references to other schemas so
you can define where this schema should
go to retrieve the information about
that in our case we are using a scholar
and we are like having all the schemas
embedded in the share as a resource so
we are providing a resource client
however you could have your own API your
own endpoint where you store all the
schemas and then all your projects that
are you validating just call this API
and retrieve the information that you
need then is as I said no is a person
seven support and then you can use the
false if you have in the schemas from
default in case that field is not there
it can use it otherwise it just ignore
it then for validating we have the
schema and the event there is a function
that I'm not showing here that is
calling this one where we extract from
the schema field which schema is from
this event we first all the other data
will receive we force them to have this
field so we can know which schema is
referencing to that is quite useful when
you have different products and you want
to have only one data collector if you
are collecting all the data from
different products or different services
with just one endpoint then you need to
to inform in the data that you are
sending which data is and what is coming
from then you have the right valuation
listener this is a contribution that we
did and I will explain in the next
slides you have the validator when you
build you have the option I just
commented so I also commented here that
the fail early if you want only to
validate I will recommend you to enable
this future because once it found some
field that is wrong then it fails it
throws an exception and it doesn't
consume more time otherwise if you want
just as our case to evaluate everything
then I will recommend you that disable
because the otherwise you will get only
one error if you fix that error
you say okay that's okay it's it's fine
now and then you you found another error
you fix it another error so it's better
if you want all the errors in the
symbolization then disable this feature
then you add the listener you perform
the validation if it fails it will throw
an exception
we are not catching it here we are
catching it in a in the father function
and then we are extracting all the
schemas reference set we will use this
part for the evolution and anonymization
I will explain why and then we just
return the result that is the composing
of this - for the listener this is a
contribution as I said before we are
quite proud of that because it helps you
to know all the soup schemas that are
matching to your Paranal schema noise
I'm saying before we have the device
sensor event that we are sending this
one is composed by the bass Evan by the
device sensor I wait device Evan and
then you have the product the device the
user you have different soup clusters
the inside and you want to know where is
referencing this so this it will help
you to know all this information how it
looks at the end now is a listener you
have different events in that case we
are just interested in two of them when
it's matching and when it's being
reference it you just receive an Evan
this Evan it contains the schema or the
location then just ask it it and then we
just adding in a buffer then once the
validation is done we just collect this
information and at the end after the
validation you have all this information
no this is how it looks a schema ref
reference that you have like all the
hash tag is the Ruth so you know get in
the Ruth path I have the best Evan the
best device the device sensor then
inside the data field I have a central
Wi-Fi and then insert the data scan e TM
0 and item one
I have the Wi-Fi connection version 1
and then in the device I have a device
but someone in the product I have
product version 3 because maybe the
product iterated to add more fields or
to have extra information or to
duplicate some of them and then we have
the user version 2 this will be quite
useful for what I'm going to explain now
how we are able evolving and animating
the data just a recap well for the this
is that evolving not allows us to keep
up the pay the the pace so are you as
you know we are iterating but also the
world is iterating now things are
changing new things are going out so we
need to be able to to prepare for that
and then also the GDP are you know we
are in here opening is has been one year
and a half or two years since GDP our
works enforced by law so by eliminating
all the data then it helps not to have
less nieghbors with lawyers and at the
end it's like more useful more helpful
for us soon as a data engineers so for
evolving analyzing we are using an open
source library developed by shifted
it's called CLT it's more or less like a
GQ x pi x query it allows you to define
your own language to transform and to
access different fields in json here you
have some examples but I will show a
realloc sample of how we are using it in
that case imagine that we have a CMS
sensor event no we perceive as a CMS
that one the first part from the the
right will be from your left will be the
the first version that we had no as you
see you can not know what it means it's
field no it's just your letters and it
has out just a few information then by
providing a CS LT expression is what is
in the box
we can then evolve to us something that
it has more
meaning no it shows more information in
that case what it provides imagine that
you have the person zero of your product
you'll launch it to the market you have
some events and then you launch the
version to other version one not to the
market where you
emigrated or you evolve your schema that
will be in that format now in Europe
right part the thing is that maybe all
there are some users that are still in
the previous version so you are
receiving both schemas you are receiving
the version zero and they were someone
and then you don't want like to store
the same information and in the same
folder because then if you want to
consume maybe you have to say okay if
version zero use this schema if person
one use that one no I don't know if how
many spark users are here or how many
athena spectrum bigquery but if when you
have different schemas then you can have
some troubles consuming this data so
what we want is to evolve and this is
the way that we are doing there is some
expressions you can do if else
statements you can have your own
functions also you can have your own
functions in Java and then call it
inside the geocell T so you don't need
to express everything in Jessel T
language and then you an ad like that
where we are evolving in that case is
the data content here is the code that
we are using for evolving now this
function its receiving the evaluation
rassul from the previous part and it's
using all the schemas reference set no
the roof that we say ok in this path we
have this a schema and then we check for
each one if there is an evil evolution
now we check if this version has an
evolution to the next one in case it
doesn't have we done evolved anything in
case we have to evolve then we will
apply this evolution we will load the
expression and then we will do a fall
left
not so we are like applying iterator
leaf to the same do leg previous result
and from the deeper or from yeah from
the deeper to the to the roof
the non-musician is using the same it's
really the same code instead of checking
has evolution we check has an
immunization how we do we check it is
that the schema reference that we are
using more or less the same path for the
expression for the shizzle the
expressions and we check if there is
something or not there that's quite easy
and for the new musician I would like to
explain some case that we found when we
were animating data this is more
didactic it's not health is a planet
except pluton but the thing is that
there are two ways of likely of
animating blacklist and white list for
the blacklist you say I don't want this
planet to be there no I don't want
proton to be a planet so I'm just
removing it and the way it is you say
okay these are the planets other thing
is not however what happens when it
arrived a human and an alien if you are
blacklisting they are will passed
so we've that identifier data then it
will go to your anonymous of data
because you're wearin aware of these new
fields no you have people on product on
the side oh why we don't add this phone
number to the data and the developers
say yeah yeah that's that's great let's
add it and they don't talk to you then
sunday you realize that you have phone
numbers in your own music data and
someone goes to you and say you have we
have no issue with the law because now I
don't know if Europe detects that we
have so sensitive data in the elicited
data so that's wrong so then you have
the whitelist option however the
whitelist is more bearable say now
because you have two explicit say this
is the data that I want so you have to
balance your needs where you want to if
you want to add more code to your
randomization or
to be lazy but then you need to be more
aware about all the flow of new fields
appearing in your data also you can
define some process to the technique
fields if you want and then trigger an
alert or something like that so we are
going to the end of the talk some
learnings that we did to this your name
about validating evolving animating is
the infrastructure that we are started
with we have an applicant way to receive
all the events from different products
we just have one endpoint so we don't
need to okay there is a new prototype
let's open any one point
no we just reduce the same for everyone
so it's like less work and less things
to maintain then we have we're
validating all the data with a lambda
and then we have all the data to penises
we have the raw data so if we messed up
we still can recover the the things and
then we have the lambda that is as I
said before we have three outputs that
we are storing in a stream and then we
also have some another lambda but is
this for indexing so we are like having
some dashboards in real time in elastic
sets to know who is look in the data
knows what one thing is having Destry
for all the bad things and building
models but also sometimes you need
something to see what is really
happening in real time
also we end up using a cache from google
guava loading the schemas for every
event that you receive it has a cost at
the foreman cost so we decided to catch
all these schemas also all the GS lt's
expressions that was reducing from two
millisecond 200 milliseconds to 4
milliseconds per evolution evaluation
because all the consumtion time it was
not validating it was building the
schema it's quite I find quite useful
there's a loading cache because you can
define the size the time and all the
process that you want to define you can
put your own matrix inside
the loading function so you can know how
many times the the cash is trying to
load and different disability things and
then some guidelines it's really
important when you are different
departments or different companies in
other cases to find some guidelines
solando it has an open source project
about the restful api is and also we had
some people from solando in our team
that they share it with us and it's
quite useful to have some guidelines
across the teams to define this because
you have people from produc and they use
a snake case other ones want to use
uppercase or different kind of things so
i will recommend you to to use this kind
of stuff and then what implies having a
data schemas no at the beginning can be
everything beautiful and easy however
you can end up having different
requirements from different teams that
are incompatible you need someone to
take ownership of the schemas even that
you can share them at the end sure with
someone trying to validate that
everything is following your own
standard and that's them and maintaining
them also so I will like also to end up
the saying thanks to to my team no it's
not just I'm here talking but all this
effort has been thanks to the team that
was behind all of this so thanks to them
and thank you to you too to be here
so if you have any questions I'm open
[Applause]
thanks for the talk wait did you to
choose JSON format instead of some
binary with which comes also with schema
built in basically which one sorry
for example there are many formats with
schemas like Avro or something like that
so yes the thing was when I joined alpha
health there was no data platform there
was no data like there was nothing so we
had like to Twitter it faster to provide
something oh no that so they could
prototype faster so we decided first to
go to kinases and have something like
easy to do and now also what we I didn't
say that we are planning to move to
Kafka and IO schemas and everything but
first it was kinases to move faster now
we'll wake Africa to move farther but at
the end is what we're I feel was nothing
there that's arisen hi first of all
thanks a lot for the presentation and
second of all my question will be have
you ever tackled issues like so I have a
sequence and in this sequence I expect
at least 10 results 40 results and they
have to be like in either arithmetic
progression geometric whatsoever do you
also have validations for that like a
sum of a series mm-hmm right now the the
way the VA it's atomic so it's per event
okay where we started taking a look to
DQ is an open source library by Amazon
to check this kind of stuff with a spark
we'll just started like a few weeks ago
to taking a look of that but right now
this is atomic
you
[Music]